hallo leute ich es wieder eure mal wanne
und willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt ja ich weiß die letzte folge
ist schon etwas länger her
und dafür möchte ich mich auch ganz
herzlich bei euch entschuldigen
entschuldigung und das comeback ist
dafür hoffentlich unsere väter denn
heute machen wir endlich endlich die
rahmen suppe aus naruto für die die
naruto vielleicht nicht kennen maputo
ist ein manga der zu einem anime gemacht
wurde
2002 war vom anime die erstausstrahlung
in japan und in deutschland war es 2006
und da liegt es auch ganz schön lange
auf rtl2 glaube ich es war tatsächlich
eins dieser animes die ich nicht so
gesucht habe ich stand dann doch eher
ich sag mal so auf die girlies sachen
also dragonball wert und so fand ich
auch alles mega aber nach route und so
im jura die haben mich nicht so abgeholt
doch einfach weiß ich und das dank euch
dass er immer wieder diese eine rahmen
suppe ist ich glaube auch irgendwie
schon in der ersten folge aber es könnte
auch in der dritten oder so sein ich hab
mir dann so die folglich gibt gibt es
tatsächlich jetzt auch auf netflix also
falls sie das mal nachschauen wollte da
haben sie es und für die rahmen suppe
brauchen wir ins team kamen nur blabla
bibeln und eier und so macht man die
suppe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und jetzt stellen wir uns natürlich
wieder der allerwichtigste frage wie
schmeckt die rahmen suppe aus naruto die
ins trudeln kommen richtig gut durch ja
- icn sie einfach sehen lassen und den
rest also dann denken wir uns einfach
dazu heute diese rahmen sockel ist
einfach schwierigkeitsstufe 9000 aber
ich möchte sie unbedingt probieren und
ihr wollt auch unbedingt sehen wie sie
schmeckt ja deswegen habe ich jemanden
gefragt der die asiatische küche besser
beherrscht als ich ankam
[Musik]
ladies und gentlemen
das ist anders ich habe ihn vor ein paar
wochen auf youtube entdeckt und was soll
ich sagen er macht die absolut geilsten
koch videos aller zeiten auf seinem
channel dreht sich alles um food food
und noch mehr wut und weil er ungefähr
dreimal so talentiert es wie ich habe
ich ihn eingeladen um ihr bei der route
suppe zu helfen
köstlich zu früh an der mesche sachen
vorbereitet die zeigt er auf seinem
zettel also falls sie gleich erstmal
sehen wollt wie man damit so einer super
anfangen sollte dann könnt ihr auch
zuerst an den videos schauen an dong
dong des videos anderes videos anderes
video schauen wir wollen darüber rahmen
sowie essen was machen wir jetzt bei
meiner wenn er jetzt sogar aus
höflichkeit extra für dich gekauft was
technisch aufwändig folge kommt merkst
du wie lange ich an naturgesetzen haben
sechs aber guter versuch voll lecker ich
habe einiges mitgebracht aber bräuchte
das vorstelle würde ich ganz gerne
den nudelteig versetzen er braucht jetzt
im moment machen rahmen und rahmen
die machen die nudeln selber also anders
würde ich das würde ich das auch gar
nicht akzeptieren entweder selber
okay das ganze weiter fallend
aber wir haben nur den satz macht
brauchen wir mehr wasser
das habe ich und jetzt brauchen wir eine
starke lage klar nein nicht da nein ich
habe fast gedacht
waking soderbergh ist oder ärger pekings
oder das tatsächlich eigentlich so
eigentlich die haus nach träume aber den
habe ich nochmal gebracht haben wie
nudeln sind nämlich immer so ein kleines
bisschen bauen und dafür ist dass da das
ist sozusagen die geheime zutat hast du
hast immer kochbuch das rezept wird
leider nicht im kochbuch sein weil ich
noch nicht kannte und absolut keine
ahnung hat wie ich jetzt machen
wer zu spät kommt den bestraft das leben
wir fangen jetzt erst mal an mit dem
medien und zwar würde ich sagen genauso
dazu mit ihren 500 gramm mehr hast du
kleine schälchen für mich wird nämlich
gerne nur das eigelb benutzen
gerade so ein als im moment überhaupt
gar nicht wieder gehen
mit dem video leute wir sind also
zeitmanagement ist richtig die neue
karte ist gekommen und sie haben an drei
gleich mitgenommen frau die anderen ist
auch noch da bist du hast dich fit for
business eine gabel die schwarze kabel
kommen wo schwarze kabel ich fühle mich
so an du triffst du die roma wurde obama
schafft ihr extra auch 1 mir gesagt ich
finde es gleich viel stärker
der wasser ungefähr 250 milliliter so
war gestern bei pekings oder bay packers
weiter wenn du zu viel rein machst aber
kein stress umgeht noch dass man fast
normal so rahmen
[Musik]
das ist ein bisschen so oft ja wie diese
stress welle der gleichheit der lustiger
straße bald raus ich bin nämlich wir
sind jetzt schon fast so weit dass du
mit dem herzen rein kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die forscher
der muss jetzt so eine viertel stunde
und 20 minuten ok nach zwischenzeit
kannst dir zeigen ausschnitt gemacht
haben jetzt kam andy und ich habe das
mal mit der base beginnt und so base ist
diese rahmenprogramms ist ein relativ
unkomplizierte früher aus schweine
rippchen 36 stunden gekocht und mich
somit gerichteten knüppel
wir haben die brüder dann gekocht hoffe
wir können die brüder schule in den
kochtopf zu bringen und das ganze mal
warm werden lassen
ja klar welchen kandidaten bringst du
rein hier so war das wohl spektakulärste
toppen war es einfach fertig ist
eigentlich sind in naruto ram eingelegte
bambus streifen drauf wie kriegt man
aber in deutschland einfach wirklich gar
nicht daher fertig eingelegtes
asiatischen staat gehört steigt aber ich
muss nicht sagen konnte sie mal aus
dieser relativ wunder betrieblichen
typischen die sauber sind ist gleich ein
bisschen karamell gibt es noch das hier
ebenso alltäglichen tüte diesen
schweinebauch habe ich geschmort in so
einer partie sofort nachdem wie das
schwein aber auch fertig war habe ich
nämlich diese gesamte soße genommen und
da drin
die eier mariniert da ist dann
eigentlich dazu machen das vielleicht
später aber ich glaube wir müssen
einfach schneiden damit wie man sich das
von innen noch einmal längst schöne
aufschneiden wir glück haben dann ist er
jetzt so ein richtig schönes
tiefere das eigelb bisschen flüssig ist
drin
ein absolutes highlight das motto magie
und mein erster versuch war diese rolle
hier wo ich fand dass die richtig schön
aussieht
leider schmeckt die nur noch gar nicht
weiter gemacht habe so eine rolle raus
brauchst bekommen
die liegt richtig die sieht ein bisschen
schöner aus die dinger heißen automarke
weil es in japan eine stadt gibt naruto
und die fraktion so eine heiße quelle
glaube ich diesen strudel förmig abfluss
hat und die das studio ist total famous
und deshalb nach der studie durch so bis
zum anschlag arbeitet also ich habe
wirklich die letzten sachen eingepackt
zwölf minuten bevor ich los gegangen bin
und ich habe noch einen versuch gehabt
mit dieser rolle war sonst ein
schlechtes gewissen so das war jetzt der
letzte versuch aber keine ahnung ob es
funktioniert hat die ist nervig wenn ihr
schaut muss nämlich noch komplett
verpacken ist das jetzt der moment
jetzt kommt der moment schauen gespannt
[Musik]
gerade haben ach komm rein doch ich
akzeptiere dass auch das sieht richtig
schön aus guck mir richtig leid für mich
in der mitte
[Musik]
okay vielleicht ein paar scheiben von
dem fleisch zu dünn dick jetzt nein ich
muss auf jeden fall einen punkt wichtig
für zug hat natürlich noch genau
also du sprichst chinesisch und russisch
und deutsch und englisch und englisch
und alles sehr gut machen
also ich bin in sankt petersburg geboren
und in berlin aufgewachsen deutschen
russischen meine muttersprache englisch
habe ich von angelina jolie gelernt mit
13 jahren 13 mal in tomb raider auf
englisch gegangen ins kino natürlich nur
weniger guten story weil ich studiert
habe es für geschichte und kultur sachen
und sowas natürlich auch und in dieser
gesamten zeit und ich mal anderen
genannt ist nämlich den edelstein name
und deshalb ist mein name anderen ja
sagt ich sah keinen pass steht
jetzt ist nicht ist nicht so schwer zu
erraten um hierdurch kann genau das
meine person welt anton widmann
normalerweise der landeshauptstadt
studiert wird okay es geht weiter mit
mit nudeln
[Musik]
er kann jetzt mal machen
das ist nämlich jetzt hier der moment
der wahrheit denkst du dir auch ein
bisschen oder ist die schöne rahmen wir
müssen ihnen so ein schönes hunde hier
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen unsere muss gar nicht
so schnell machen nur dass bewegung ist
sozusagen das die nicht stillten
mein gott ist ja ganz schön viele rahmen
einmal kurz aufkochen hier
wenn man ihn so macht dann geht es
schneller mein bruder gibt ja diesen
fällt diese werde ich wir können ab
diesen sogar muss sich jetzt mental
vorbereiten darauf es könnte nämlich
tatsächlich eine lebensverändernde
vereinigt werden weiß ich nicht nur weil
hier schön folge
das ist sondern auch gute portion auf
jeden fall weitergeht
[Musik]
das reicht schon auch mal schön erhalten
und jetzt und der moment der wahrheit
hast du noch mal eine vorlage für uns
sich eins zu eins nachbauen ganz
deutlich so genau 12 wird schon ganz gut
aus
so jetzt ein heil bis jetzt unser
schönes eingelegt ganz wichtig ist der
daumen
hier kann man sich ja nach rahmen war es
sieht schon mal gut aus bei der zweite
portion legen wir richtig läuft jetzt
[Musik]
und jetzt stellen wir uns wieder
wichtigsten frage wie schnecken die
rahmen auch nach gut okay leute so das
klima wäre heute das gleich probieren
wir werden noch mal ein ganzes video zum
thema fleisch machen aber für heute will
ich jetzt einfach mal so ist die suppe
probiert und so fühl mich so gar nicht
selbst gemacht nur jetzt richtig schön
schlürfen neun stunden wenn du nicht
schluss heißt es schmeckt nämlich
anderen diese nudeln
das erste was ich jemals in meinem leben
gegessen habe und dass ich immer zu
meinem leben vergessen haben
ich kenne ja schon nicht aber jetzt mit
dir im kontext das eingelegte zeigt
nämlich durch und eine also wirklich
premiere seit drei jahren glaube ich auf
meinem kanal
ich finde mich gehört weiter hart
[Musik]
habe ich auch noch nicht gegessen noch
nie was sagst du weißt du noch wie
fleisch schmeckt sojasauce mir ist es so
eine art süße reiswein aus dem kreis
gehört gar nicht wo es dir halt mein
video chance herauszufinden schaut jetzt
nochmal bitte unbedingt vorbei ich bin
schon großer fan ein toller moment ihr
werdet auch große fans seien abonniert
imam seine videos in mega cool und ich
habe kein cool verabschiedet also licon
abonnieren kommentare lassen schreibt
mir was für ein mensch ich bin weil ich
schwanger ist oder ignoriert einfach
diesen fahrten lassen nicht leben
dankeschön bis dann
[Musik]
und jetzt richtig rein frisst